aún queda una luz tenue de esperanza por
encontrar sobrevivientes bajo los
escombros a pesar de las más de 200
horas del devastador terremoto varias
personas lograron volver a la superficie
Este martes
risa es uno de los más de 158.000 que
han evacuado la vasta región afectada en
Turquía
[Música]
gracias a Dios no hay muchos daños en
nuestra casa hay grietas en las paredes
pero los contratistas roban
continuamente por eso estoy separando
nuestra casa y estoy enviando a mis
hijos lejos para que no mueran
sobrevivimos en una noche al terremoto
que no habíamos visto en mil años
esto es muy duro Dios quiera que nadie
pase por esto empezaremos de cero sin
muebles sin sentimientos ya no tenemos
familiares Allí están todos en lugares
diferentes
en El auxilio las labores de rescate
terminaron la ayuda humanitaria de este
país golpeado no solo por los sismos
sino por años de guerra civil proviene
de emiratos árabes Unidos y Arabia
Saudita y llegan a las zonas bajo el
control gubernamental el primer convoy
de ayuda de la ONU arribó hoy a una
región controlada por los Rebeldes la
alta comisionada adjunta de acnur visitó
a lepo donde instalaron unos 200 centros
para refugiados
[Aplausos]
estamos tratando de ampliar la ayuda
trabajando sin descanso para poder
prestar lo antes posible muchas casas
Están destruidas muchas personas están
desplazadas Y esto llega después de otra
crisis que ha afectado profundamente a
este país durante los últimos 12 años
en la actualidad la ONU solo puede
suministrar ayuda a la zona
noroccidental de it a través de un único
paso fronterizo en agua tras ocho días
de la catástrofe la crisis humanitaria
aumenta las víctimas mortales se cuentan
por miles